what do you think the single most
important thing we need to be doing
right now as Americans and as a country
is well the very first thing is the
social isolation so that the number of
contacts outside your household is
minimized and you know washing your
hands distancing as much as possible
those are going to cause this
exponential growth in the infection to
both level off you know hopefully in the
next month we'll see that leveling off
and most of the country and then as we
go another month after that we need to
get the numbers down pretty dramatically
so that then we can look at what
activities we start to open back up do
you think there should be a national
policy absolutely as long as people are
moving around within the country we're
all in this together it's not likely
we're going to partition the country
into all sorts of separate pieces
because things like food and electricity
there are essential functions where we
still want people to be connected so
it'll help everyone get out of this more
quickly and reduce the deaths and reduce
the economic reduction if we implement
these strong isolation measures on a
countrywide basis but we obviously have
some states taking different policies
than others do you think we need
leadership from the White House that
we're not getting I think that the
pressure by fellow governors the
executive branch the experts should be
very strong so that all 50 governors are
seen that they need to do this or that
there is a federal order about the
social isolation the sooner you start
the less cases you're going to have and
the sooner we can all go back to some
level of normalcy earlier this year the
Gates Foundation gave a hundred million
dollars towards fighting this virus what
specifically is that money doing to help
Americans right now
yeah our foundation works a lot on
diagnostics and vaccines
and understanding how to make new
vaccines make them in large quantity
that's what we're doing all the time
that's caused us to understand about
this pandemic risk and talk about it
going back a long time when this
particular virus hit we saw that getting
the testing capacity up very rapidly
would be very very key and so there's a
number of companies we work with on that
you know I've done conference calls with
the drug companies with talked with the
diagnostic companies to really get this
response so that we can see what's going
on testing is important drugs to reduce
the disease so we created the
therapeutics accelerated for that and
then we're working closer to the vaccine
companies and they're the ones although
it's probably 18 months or so they're
the ones that can really get things back
to where we're not worried about large
public gatherings you think it's 18
months at the soonest well if everything
went perfectly you could do somewhat
better than that but I wouldn't want to
create an expectation for something
quicker we've got to make sure it's safe
we have to build up the manufacturing
capacity and you know our team as
experts about vaccines works with dr.
pouchy and his team and I think we've
got a very common message about the work
that needs to be done there where do you
think money needs to go most critically
first at this point in time well the
critical supplies the ventilators the
masks the protective equipment obviously
that is the most urgent thing to help
the healthcare personnel the testing
capacity you know so that somebody knows
within 24 hours if they're at all
symptomatic we should get them a home
test 24 hours later they should know for
sure so that they can isolate themselves
completely and not have bad infection
lead to many other infections over time
it's going to be building that for all
the vaccine constructs that there's
seven or more that look promising
have to build factories in parallel with
testing the safety and advocacy knowing
that only probably two of the vaccines
will be the ones we go ahead with so
it's risky but you know it's so
important to get not just hundreds of
millions but literally billions of those
vaccines because this is a global
problem and although the u.s. is not the
most cases right now as time goes on the
developing countries where isolation is
more difficult and the health system is
very weak sadly they're most likely to
experience the most pain of all as as
this goes global you've been saying for
a long time that we're not prioritizing
testing who should be leading the way
here well the federal government needs
to set the priorities because we have a
lot of people were just worried who
would like to get a test and if we had
infinite capacity that would be great
and so as many as half of our tests are
going to the people they shouldn't and
that's causing you'd have to wait often
three or four days even if your health
care worker to get that result back
those results should be coming back
within 24 hours because we're
appropriately prioritizing the contact
tracing and those who are truly
symptomatic as the ones that use up that
testing capacity back in 2015 you warned
that we were not ready for the next
epidemic why aren't we better prepared
well in fact very little investment was
made into for example being able to ramp
up diagnostic capacity very quickly and
so we could have done work from you know
2015 or even earlier to do that likewise
the ability to make the antiviral drugs
to make the antibodies to make the
vaccines our foundation and some other
governments did work on some new vaccine
platforms which are the most promising
that are being accelerated here during
this epidemic but you know sadly because
you can't estimate the risk and it was
something I was
you know I'm trying to talk about and
you know thought we had some engagement
on but then actually the personnel in
this area were were cut back so you know
I think this time people understand that
this is a trillions of dollars event
it's going to be hundreds of thousands
of lives on a on a global basis I think
now people understand why those alarms
were raised and that for the next one we
will be far more ready than we were for
this one how concerned are you about the
resiliency of the American economy well
the economy is being hurt and that's
translating to uncertainty people losing
their jobs businesses that are having a
hard time financing their costs it's
great that Congress has acted we
probably will need to do more there but
with the economy you know we can bring
it back you know there will be a point
where we have the vaccine and we're
going completely back to normal and
we'll go somewhat back to normal if if
we do the right things not even that
long from now but you know the economy
can return in a way that people who get
sick and die cannot and so we're having
to prioritize this isolation to minimize
the medical impact and it's
unprecedented it's unnerving the numbers
will certainly be in the even larger I
think was four trillion I put into my
2015 speech and I thought wow that is a
big number but in fact that's what I
estimated World Bank had done an
estimate but this is going to be much
bigger than that
yeah you've been in touch with leaders
in Washington have you talked with the
president about this I've not talked
directly to the president our foundation
is trying to be as helpful in a very
constructive way as possible and that's
why I've talked to the head of the
pharmaceutical companies we've talked to
a lot of the agencies and
Tooting CDC and NIH about how we work
together on the vaccine and the drugs
you know our foundation works so much in
these areas that you know we're pitching
in to accelerate the the solutions in a
cooperative fashion so immense dialogue
all you know being done on a digital
basis so from what you see in terms of
the response so far have we got anything
right is there any reason to be
optimistic about the way we've responded
to this epidemic well there are
countries that responded very quickly so
Taiwan you know realized very early on
what needed to be done
South Korea ramped up their testing and
did the prioritization so you're getting
those tests back quickly China
dropped the number of cases so
dramatically that they are starting to
open up now you wouldn't say they're
back to normal right yeah but they you
know that's a very good sign that if you
take strong measures which were not as
strong on a countrywide basis as they
are but you know the fact that now they
can have the factories run have kids
going back to school that's kind of a
model and very hopeful even in parts of
the United States you know we're
starting to see him certainly by the end
of the month I expect we'll see that the
regions that shut down and did it best
the numbers will have plateaued and
that's what you see before they start to
come down so you know we understand what
needs to be done here it's going to be
very painful but taking the pain early
means there's a lot less pain both
medically and economically than if we
did dally and wait until every town has
big numbers before we react some people
are somewhat suspicious of the numbers
coming out of China do you trust the
statistics coming out of China oh within
you know 10 or 20 percent the numbers
about what's going on the last few
months they wouldn't be opening up they
wouldn't be closing the
so you know clearly they turned the tide
in the early stage you know they could
have reacted faster up until in January
late January they took those huge
measures but you know people shouldn't
let their views about a country not let
it inform them about okay what's really
worked there why is it that they can go
back to work and not see their hospitals
fill up so yes they they definitely
turned the tide we'll argue about the
case definitions and the exact numbers
for a long time out into the future but
it is the most important evidence here
is the intervention they took went from
an exponential increase to a decrease
even if if though there's some some
uncertainty it's a dramatic decrease
you've called for something that you
call germ games to prepare for the next
pandemic what exactly would that entail
well the United States and other
countries but the United States most of
all you know spends like six hundred
billion in year to prepare for something
that's uncertain to prepare for a war
and you know it it may not come but
you're willing to make that investment
and you make sure you have readiness by
doing exercises where you try out
different scenarios so here with a
pandemic you know which the chance over
20-year period was always very high and
that's what I was trying to get people
to focus on you have to try out you know
can you make tests really quickly how do
you connect to the vaccine companies
what money could you give them in
advance that would reduce the 18 months
that we're having to deal with now you
know understanding this who should get
these tests so if you did a bunch of
simulations all of these issues would
have been thought through and you would
have a game plan that you would activate
you know like the countries that because
of their SARS experience you know did a
very good job on the current epidemic
and so
we'll need to be you know certainly tens
of billions of dollars put into this
readiness these German games like
wargames that will really test out our
systems and make sure that we move
faster than the virus does which in the
early stage here was not the case
the last drill we had was what back in
2001 yeah there was apparently people
are talking about I'm I'm not an expert
on it the Obama administration
apparently decided to do some flu
activity and look at that I don't think
that's that that's been made public in
terms of exactly what was figured out
there but the one that I do know about
goes back to the 2001 it was called dark
winter and that was a smallpox
simulation now smallpox really is
horrific because it's an over 30 percent
death rate in that case they the people
who did it saw that again we were not
prepared the germ in that case would
have won the war why do you think we've
been reluctant to do this kind of
preparedness I'm not sure you know some
countries and our Foundation and
Wellcome Trust did put money in to see
epi which is about vaccine platforms to
be ready for some new pathogen that
comes along so there'd been modest
investments and of course the general
progress of science of how we do
molecular testing how we can build
antibodies all these things are
advancing and so in fact that's what
gives you the scientific basis to be
able to build pandemic tools that can be
put to work very quickly what people
have to get mind is that time is so
important because you have this
exponential growth and in my you know
2015 clock I show in that case another
respiratory virus a flu spreading
throughout the entire world literally in
in a matter of a few months and so the
difference between early action where
you have the tools and you have the
training and then are waiting 2 or 3
months that's a night and day difference
yeah
a significant portion of the 100 million
dollars that you're committing to
fighting this virus goes to Africa where
they've not had a significant outbreak
there yet
how concerned are you about Africa I'm
very concerned about Africa and all the
developing countries as you say the
number of cases is not large yet now
that's partly because their capacity to
test is very limited the number of these
PCR machines they have is far less than
the United States which actually has by
far the most and their ability to social
distance is limited it may be that the
seasonality in the southern hemisphere
is holding back infections and so it'll
start to accelerate in a few months that
would be good news for the northern
hemisphere to have a period of six
months of less force of an infection but
unless there's some surprise thing that
means the virus doesn't do well in those
countries they're likely in the end to
have the greatest economic damage and
the greatest number of deaths and you
know we should care about that as humans
we should also care because we need to
get rid of this disease from the entire
world
to avoid the chance that you get
reinfection coming back into countries
who've already gotten it down to low
levels as much as you looked at the
potential of a pandemic occurring is
there anything that's really surprised
you about what's happened in in the case
of the corona virus you know I thought
we would respond a bit faster you know
even for me who works in this area
though the idea of the what we're doing
how we're having to change the economy
here in order to drop the number of
cases it's you know it's really
unprecedented and you know we're kind of
an unchartered territory about how we
minimize the pain even the issue of once
you get the case numbers down there's a
lot of dialogue between our foundation
experts and the government now but what
does opening up look like you know which
activities have like schools have such
benefit and can be done
a way that the risk of transmission is
very low yeah
and which activities like mass
gatherings maybe in a certain sense more
optional and so until you're widely
vaccinated those may not come back at
all
so how long do you think this is going
to last well I believe that by the end
of the month I hope we see the number of
cases plateauing in the United States
the numbers will drive the actions we
take but for places that do the shutdown
well you should start to see that peak
then if you go another four weeks those
numbers will come down quite a bit if
you maintain the measures if you're not
getting lakhs and those things and then
you can get it to a low enough level
that the ability to test and trace
contacts of the remaining people will be
very verify and so some degree of
opening up is possible I've said six to
ten weeks but again every every week as
we look at those numbers it'll help us
see you know how much longer we'll have
to be in this really extreme mode where
we're not out mixing around yeah so
you're talking about midsummer probably
at the earliest where things are kind of
feeling like normal again well I'd say
for the the places that started early
you know I do see that by the end of May
they could have very few cases but it'll
be tough if we have other parts of the
country that we're still mixing with
that have a lot of cases there and so
you know lots of testing to get us those
numbers so we can make these judgments
well strong response throughout the
country those are the two things that
would tell us haze is May going to be
the right time at the end of May the
seasonality the virus which were still
not sure about nobody wants to promise
that that's there to help us that could
as we're getting into spring and summer
help reduce the number of infections
that you know for things like flu other
respiratory viruses
big deal and so the data is is going to
be key and as we do the testing in the
right way that data will be very very
solid as a guide to what the next step
is mm-hmm what how do you prioritize who
gets tested the key for testing is
health workers people have essential
jobs contacts of people who are tested
positive or people who have the symptoms
people are just worried and don't really
have the symptoms unfortunately are a
lot of the tests going on right now
until we're super ramped up you know
that should not be using up the critical
capacity so we can get to under 24 hours
the results to all of those very
critical people some of them we have
machines only a small part of our
capacity that's even faster so like the
health care worker should be getting an
answer and more like an hour with the
quick turnaround machines today many
tests wait about three days even the
really urgent ones and that's
unacceptable you've not only studied
pandemics you've also run a major
American company which is you have two
credentials most people don't have
together what do you think the prognosis
for the American economy is how long do
you think it will take for it to come
back well the economy will come back you
know as we start to open up and and are
able to have people go back to almost
all jobs as the schools are resuming you
know you'll start to see that recovery
it will probably be years before you get
back to where you were before because of
the time in people this is a big
economic shock and some things we really
will want to be broadly vaccinated
before we're not worried about this and
it's changing our behavior in a
significant way so it is definitely the
case it will take years to come back but
it can come back and it will come back
what do you think the chance of another
outbreak in the fall or the winter is
well we'll understand
the seasonality that bar
within a few months that is we'll see
are the infection levels in the southern
hemisphere going up we'll see if the
force of infection here goes down and so
it would be very good if this virus was
seasonal because the northern hemisphere
where most people live it would bias a
six-month period to really get our act
together in terms of masks Diagnostics
protective equipment understanding the
drugs that can save lives here and a lot
of progress on the vaccine so you know
we're all hoping that it's more like flu
in its seasonality even though if you
say you when the fall Dex comes you you
better not have relaxed you better be
ready for that force of infection to go
back up is life ever gonna be the same
do you think I'm not for some time I
mean you know everybody who's lived
through this will view this as a
dramatic scary part of their life and it
will affect you know their concerns and
how they looked at things for the rest
of time should be the same should life
ever be the same
well if if we had been prepared you know
then it wouldn't have become this huge
dramatic thing and there will be not a
lot but some countries like Taiwan that
it appears you know won't have to go
through this kind of shut down because
they were so good at seeing the cases
coming into the country and contact
tracing and testing with really quick
results what was going on there so you
know I you know after World War two
things were never the same we drop we
drop nuclear bombs
so the vigilance and the investment and
using the best science to be ready for
one then there will be another one we
can't say when but if you take a 20 year
time period it's a it's a substantial
risk but the idea of big public
gatherings I do believe once we have the
vaccination then the kind of fears and
the change of behavior around that
it could definitely be pretty close to
where it was before this started mm-hmm
do you think where we're gonna think
about pandemics differently from now on
well that is for sure I you know there
were a few movies they weren't that
popular about this and to make them at
least a little bit popular they usually
had some miracle happen at the end where
some hero you know invented something
and boom everything was back to normal
no the awareness of this is a threat and
probably the biggest threat to you know
kill tens of millions of people that
will be permanently embedded so this
time I do think we will get ourselves
ready for the next pandemic have you had
any trouble getting adjusted to social
distancing at home yeah I find it so
disconcerting to wake up every morning
and think well that was a strange dream
I had and then say oh my god yes you
know look there's no traffic on the
bridge and oh yeah my first meeting is
on that computer screen and my second
meetings on that computer screen and you
know I'm somebody's gonna leave some
food but I won't see them this is super
dramatic you know I use computer screens
a lot and I think about pandemics a lot
and even so I can hardly believe we're
in this situation mm-hmm it is it's and
every day it's different isn't it and
yeah and you know we need to orchestrate
the numbers the science the innovation
and we need to do it very very quickly
and you know there are amazing health
workers and scientists rising to the
occasion here and you know thank God for
that
one last question ultimately did the
federal government fail on being
prepared for testing well I'm sure
there'll be lots of post-mortems about
you know why before this hit didn't we
do more why you know right when it hit
didn't we do more you know right now I
think it's most important to be looking
forward and saying
are the number of tests growing is the
speed which they come back less than 24
hours and are we testing the right
people we're still not there and so
let's get that fixed and then we can you
know maybe a year from now do the deep
post-mortems Bill Gates thanks very much
for being with us please stay healthy
thank you